قال وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري ان
بلاده وفرنسا متفقتان على رفض سياسه
التهجير في حق سكان قطاع غزه وعلى ضروره
وقف اطلاق النار ودخول المساعدات
الانسانيه وفي مؤتمر صحفي مع رظيله
الفرنسي في القاهره قال شكري ان التطورات
الجاريه في المنطقه بسبب حرب غزه تنذر
بالتفاقم الوضع والانزلاق الى صراع
اوسع خطوره اتساع رقعه الصراع في الشرق
الاوسط
اتصالا بالحرب في غزه ما نشهده من تهديد
للملاحه في البحر
الاحمر اعمال العسكريه ال تمت في سوريا
وفي في
العراق ايضا الاوضاع العسكريه على الحدود
الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه كلها تنذر بتفاقم
الوضع والانزلاق الى صراع اوسع وهذا ما
نسعى لتجنبه من خلال المطالبه بضروره وقف
اطلاق النار في غزه والتعامل مع
القضايا بمنظور سياسي شامل